hallo ich meine lieben frauen und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung in minecraft und zwar über
die wir wahrscheinlich mit der löschung
gesehen habt eine rollercoaster motto
wir sehen hier schon dass ich einen
kleinen trick gebaut habe einen kleinen
trick eine kleine bahn gebaut habt wo
man hier direkt ein content die
dopingjäger barrel rodan noch ein
looping ist eine kurve noch einen
looping
denn hier nochmal barrel rodan fährt man
hier runter hier wieder hoch blablabla
dann ist man wieder am start hier kann
man nicht durchlaufen weil das ganze
zwei blöcke hoch ist erstmal
download-links et cetera alles ist in
der beschreibung auch die kraft in
sachen wie man sich die sachen kräfte
dct er hatte ich jetzt keine lust und
habe mich mal negatives feedback
bekommen wenn ich zum video gemacht hat
deswegen fand ich einfach das video von
entwickler und den download link in der
beschreibung damit ihr euch da die
sachen anschauen könnt wie man das
kräfte derzeit drei und ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt an
wir haben hier das ganz normale inventar
und hier eine seite weiter haben wir die
rollercoaster decoration die
rollercoaster tracks die roller coaster
tools und die rollercoaster misc all die
sachen die noch hinzugefügt werden also
die sind zwar schon drin aber die sache
deshalb man kann diese rollercoaster
noch nicht fahren
das ist ganze ich muss eine kleine
vorgeschichte zu dieser modifikation
erzählen und zwar ich weiß nicht ob ich
modbus sagt aber das ist so ein
wettbewerb so weit wie ich das
verstanden habe
wo ganz viele individuelle personen oder
unabhängige entwickler quasi mods
erstellen können und dafür drei tage
zeit haben und das ist eine motto raus
das heißt sie hatten das vor kurzer zeit
erst war dieses motto und die haben
quasi nicht so viel zeit das ganze jetzt
noch neu hinzuzufügen so alle möglichen
sachen zu machen und deswegen macht den
leuten da keinen stress jetzt ist ganz
kurz gewackelt macht den leuten da
keinen stress wird noch hinzugefügt dass
man damit auch wirklich fahren kann
ladet euch die man von mir auch schon
mal runter damit ihr da wirklich auf dem
neuesten stand seit wann das wirklich
weitergeht und eventuell schon mal ein
track bauen können dieser hier ist jetzt
noch sehr schlecht sagt ich mal das
gleiche die sind schon um berge rum und
alles mögliche da kann man richtig gute
sache machen und durch den berg durch
und keine ahnung ich finde sowas ganz
cool wenn das oft server noch bald
gemacht wird dass man dann so ein roller
coaster roth macht und dadurch dann
quasi den server entdecken kann und ich
leider wieder viel zu viel drum rum
ich will sagen ich fange jetzt mal an
mit dem decoration sie sind ganz viele
neue sachen hinzugefügt worden wie
beispielsweise an asphalt ab dass die
sandy lief wie ochs russ woodbridge
mangels enstone und quarz ich habe hier
einfach mal diese ganz normalen
autoteile hin gebaut
es gibt ja sogar sie dass die was
einfach so aus erde ist ein paar wege
über die man halt so drüber laufen kann
und dann gerne um das ganze als ein
bisschen schöner zu gestalten
halt wie der name schon sagt es sind
einfach decoration leave it is halt
genau das gleiche nur noch mit so ein
paar blättern drauf und ja also wenn
später irgendwie sondern liefert würde
ich beispielsweise bauen und dann die
ganze bahn in dieser farbe hier färben
dass man so einen weg entlang sondern
ist die farbe in sandton und läuft dann
irgendwie durch eine wüste durch wieder
irgendwie so dass mit einer ganz ganz
viele sachen später machen und dann habe
ich auch sachen wie zum beispiel
mailings picket fences oder diese fans
ist hier beispielsweise die sind so und
dann kann man darauf kurven dran bauen
etc das ganze habe ich hier schon so ein
bisschen gebaut um das ganze ein
bisschen abzusperren also das sind
wirklich nur dekoration ganz ganz viele
verschiedene sachen die man da machen
kann
die beispielsweise hier sieht man das
auch in alle richtungen gehen
und jetzt haben wir nämlich schon das
erste problem was ihr seht und zwar sind
die immer gleich egal wie ich gucke sind
die sachen immer gleich wie ich die
hinsetze das kann man allerdings
verändern und zwar gibt es einen track
maintain stool will seine hammer mit dem
könnte einfach rechts ich drauf machen
und dann kann man diese ganzen sachen
drehen ich kann auch hier diese kurve
komplett drehen
genau das gleiche funktioniert auch hier
beispielsweise bei dem roller coaster
bei ganz normalen blöcken geht das
selbstverständlich nicht
aber hier geht das ganze es geht
wirklich bei allen sachen die man hier
legen wie drin hat also hier irgendwie
bei den kurven bei allen wirklich lachen
und dann kann man auch hier
beispielsweise sowas nutzen um seinen
vier geteilten raum zu machen ganz ganz
wieder möglichkeiten sind da gegeben bei
den deckel relations dann gibt es die
tracks worauf wir natürlich alle
gewartet habt ich packe man hier ganz
kurz die sachen so hin
das sind erstmal so diese tracks die man
eigentlich am meisten braucht diese mal
ein bisschen soll das ist dieser ganz
normale track wenn man den allerdings so
bauen will hier kennt das problem dann
muss man wieder dementieren summer
nehmen allerdings jetzt erst mal anders
als bei den rails die minecraft
hinzugefügt werden also bei diesen
sachen bei denen ist es ja so wenn ich
die mauer dann passen die sich anna
machen die automatisch eine kurve
das ist hier nicht so da muss man
nämlich eine kurve hin bauen und diese
ist jetzt auch falsch das heißt wenn ihm
das mental nichts tun und wir haben eine
kurve das heißt man kann hier so rum
fahren das verbindet sich blablabla da
kann man hier ins leopard trek machen
ist wieder falsche moment erinnern stool
so und dann geht es hier hoch
so jetzt denke ich natürlich wie macht
man es jetzt weiter man kann jetzt
natürlich die einfachen blog hinsetzen
und hier track drauf bauen und einfach
so machen dann sieht man aber dass
verbindet sich nicht zeigt man muss sich
da schon irgendwas anderes überlegen
da gibt es nämlich einerseits noch
dieses lob trägt er einfach so weiter
nach oben geht das heißt ich schätze mal
ganz kurz drauf und dann seht ihr jetzt
schon okay der iss entfernt
das ist nämlich die einzige sache man
muss ja immer so ein bisschen nachdenkt
das heißt ich mache jetzt das hier
mal ganz kurz weg macht ihr mal den hin
setzt ihn mal in die richtung macht dass
sie wieder weg und packt jetzt hier den
hierhin und dem wieder mit dem internen
zimmer und zack jetzt sind die beiden
verbunden jetzt geht das hier nämlich
schon ein stück höher oder kann man
jetzt ein bisschen höher fahren
so jetzt möchten wir natürlich gerade
kommen durch dieses stück hier
das macht das ganze nicht wieder gerade
wenn wir das jetzt machen wollen wird ja
auch schon wieder wenn ich den hier
drauf setze so sagt wenn ich gehen jetzt
ein bisschen drehe geht wieder nicht
heißt ich muss den quasi hier hinsetzen
sorgt das halb fertig nun mache ist die
sätze dass hier wieder weg mache so so
so so zack zack setzte hier den hierhin
neben dem endeavour macht so macht er
wieder weg und jetzt kommt der
soundtrack kommt wieder hierhin als
logmein ich natürlich nichts lob abwehr
slot track so den dreh ich jetzt hier
wieder dass der dazu passt und jetzt
kommt hier dieser ganz normale hin und
die drei in europa jetzt haben die ganz
normale steigung nach oben jetzt können
wir das ganze noch verschönern
indem wir einfach jetzt moment bin auf
der falschen seite indem einfach von
hier und track support polen nehmen das
heißt das sind einfach so ganz normale
teile wie können wir da bauen damit das
ganze ein bisschen schöner aussieht das
wird natürlich auch so halten allerdings
formen das ganze natürlich ein bisschen
schöner machen so da können wir hier
oben eventuell auch mal das druckbild
alles noch ein bisschen weil das in der
neuesten version das ist wirklich die
sehr gut dass ich den sand blog das
inventar geholt habe es ist wirklich die
einst 7.10 die noch nicht so ganz stabil
läuft
so ich habe jetzt so gebaut jetzt
nämlich beispielsweise wieder ein ganz
normalen trek setzte den hierhin so
nebenzimmer hole mir dann beispielsweise
von hier noch ebenso nur kurve postreg
setzt den hier drauf dann kann man das
ganze weiter und könnte theoretisch
dieses ganze gebilde jetzt noch einmal
nach unten bauen dann geht das hier
wieder runter aber natürlich nicht gegen
den charakter sondern von dem kaktus weg
und dann können wir das ganze weiter
bauen wir können da jetzt auch einfach
mal so ein barrel rohöl dran bauen das
sind mich schon die weiterführenden
dinge die hinzugefügt werden und zwar
hab ich euch die einfachen teil jetzt
gezeigt es werde nämlich auch loopings
und diese barrel hardliner wall tracks
hinzugefügt das heißt ich einen looping
ansetzen dann geht es so weiter
mach das mal ganz kurz dass ich hier so
ich mache das muss nicht schön aussehen
eben so ich baue dir den track mal eben
weiter und jetzt setzt sich jemals ein
barrel rohöl daran dass falsche richtung
das heißt in dem den hammer moment
moment ich möchte mal eben einen moment
bla bla bla bla bla man muss sich halt
an diese ganze kg noch dann wird ein
ganz klein wenig dran gewöhnt wo man die
teile hinsetzen muss so einen noch
weiter also das ist es weshalb wieso die
mod ist in den kinderschuhen gerade noch
also jetzt passt alles
jetzt haben wir quasi schon mal so einen
ersten kleinen trick der jetzt kein ende
hat aber man fährt quasi hier los mit
dem ganz normalen trek hat hier eine
kurve drin fährt hier weiter hat jedes
lob ab es lob und lockdown wieder hat
man hier wieder eine kurve hat manieren
looping wieder normal trainieren barrel
dann geht sie weiterhin wieder nach
unten und dann gibt's hier hinten
vielleicht noch um vielleicht noch mal
ein looping david dass ihr verbunden
jetzt denke ich erst mal okay das sieht
allerdings ein bisschen langweilig aus
wir können das ganze nämlich noch
verschönern
indem wir ganz einfach hier von den
roller coaster tools beispielsweise in
pain branche nehmen dann können wir
einfach richtig drauf machen so werden
beispielsweise irgendwann nicht mehr
wissen welche farbe das war können wir
einfach ein 1 1 p gedrückt halten
richtig drauf machen dann aber wieder
den payne brosch und jetzt können wir
hier quasi alles in diesem das ist das
wo im magenta cyan genau spüren farben
machen
so jetzt habe ich alles in vielen farben
genau das gleiche können wir auch mit
diesen teilen ihr machen für die teile
drauf stehen hier genau wenn wir alles
für anfahren machen ich habe hier
beispielsweise führen da benutzt und da
hinten lassen die ganzen fahren die man
verwenden kann die sind doch hier genau
das gleiche mit dem pen backes
habt ihr diese sachen die hier
hinzugefügt werden wie beispielsweise
der reit operator ski der nps und der ss
android ticket das sind sachen die
versprechen schon viel in der zukunft
und zwar kann man daraus dann
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal komplette
freizeitparks bauen also wir sehen hier
komplette ein eintrittsticket wir sehen
hier ein waldfest also was ich mir für
die zukunft eventuell denke was
hinzugefügt wird
ist das wirklich so ein kleines häuschen
dahin kommt und man muss an seinem pass
ein game dann bekommt man im kart und da
kam das kater draufsetzen kann dann
darum fahren
ihr seht hier schon chains das ein ganz
normal diese teile die verbinden ganz
einfach change ganz normale verkettung
also die können wir einfach dran
platzieren dann wird das ganze hier mehr
oder weniger miteinander verbunden dass
das ganze quasi das testat nicht in
gehaus fliegt oder irgendwie so was also
ist noch alles oder mache die meisten
sachen die kann auch friction brakes und
reels anpacken hier friction brakes und
die ganzen funktionen funktionieren erst
wenn die mod wirklich zurzeit ist glaub
ich ja so ein 1.3 oder 1.4 in der neuen
land entweder 1.415 wären dann noch
weitere dinge hinzugefügt hier haben wir
beispielsweise auch noch wo ich gerade
noch gar nicht zu bekommen denn den
track fabricated den track storage und
den track designer und was diese track
teile machen das sind nämlich die drei
sachen die das ganze ein bisschen ich
meinen teams hätten 0
die das ganze ist ein bisschen schöner
gestalten und zwar seht ihr hier schon
höhe was das denn jetzt hat man
minecraft abgestürzt auch sehr schön ich
hab grad noch mal probiert das ganze
aufzunehmen mit dem also nochmal eine
zweite aufnahme gestartet nachdem das
ganze abgeschüttelt abgestürzt ist und
es liegt wahrscheinlich an diesem track
fabrik älter ich kann das ding nicht
öffnen ich blende euch da jetzt mal eben
einen screenshot von 1 weil irgendwie
das ganze läuft noch nicht so richtig
also das ganze ist quasi wirklich noch
was sie daran auch gesehen haben es ist
alles noch in der mache ist ist auf
jeden fall krass dass dieser typ der
entwickler das ganze schon drei tagen
geschafft hat in diesen tagen aus aber
visconti mich darüber gerne in den
kommentaren informieren aber ich finde
auf jeden fall schon mal geradeaus alles
hingekriegt das ganze läuft noch nicht
stabil habe ich wollte ich den mal
trotzdem schon mal zeigen damit man
sieht was ist alles mögliche minecraft
und auf was für einem weg befinden wir
uns
dieser track barricaid hab ich euch
gerade ein bild von eingeblendet ihr
seht da da kann man in diesem text eric
hater kann man sachen diese rails kaufen
und zwar beispielsweise ein ganz
normaler track kostet drei eisen da muss
man eisen oben links rein legen und
unten links kommt dann wenn man drei
eingelegt hat und einst ausgewählt hat
kommt dann ein track raus und dafür
haben wir dann auch noch den track
storage und zwar kann man hier nicht
solche dinge wie sand reinpacken ich
klicke hier drauf das geht nicht wenn
ich da versuche eisenbahn zu packen geht
auch nicht wenn ich allerdings einfach
mal so ein track nehme und den darf
außerdem hinsetzen kleiner fehler geht
das ganze also das ist am trekstor
patrick ich nur für die tracks da seht
ihr es extra schon so einen schlüssel in
form einer mutter von tanz augen ist
auch sega und dann haben wir hier noch
den track designer also ich sehe dass
man ganz kurzen 2 der track designer so
sieht der aus ist ein bisschen geld wird
zum kran dran
krankhafter und zwar können einfach
rechts drauf machen ein kommers mit bea
ist leser ein bisschen herum bewegen
können uns das ganze angucken hier wie
das ganze gebaut ist wundervoll
michael page ab und page town drücken um
hoch und runter zu fliegen dann können
wir drücken und das ganze nach links so
rotieren krücken das ganze nach rechts
zu rotieren und shift weh und das ganze
nach oben zu rotieren und shift essen
das ganz nach unten zu rotieren
seit wir können hiermit quasi jetzt mal
versuchen direkt an mich ran zu fliegen
so männchen in morgen weg sagt da bin
ich mit meiner teilen mono brauer der
openscape drücken sind wieder raus
imtech designer kann man bisher nichts
mache das sind halt wirklich alles
sachen die schon hinzugefügt wurden aber
in folgenden updates wird den ganzen
teil noch eine funktion zugeordnet
aber ich bin es auf jeden fall richtig
krass was soll mit dieser mod schon
alles machen kann ihr könnt euch einfach
mal runterladen und eventuell bilder
posten von euren rollercoaster die ihre
erbaut und ich finde auf jeden fall
richtig krass ich habe da schon welche
gesehen im forum wo welche das wirklich
durch den berg durch gebaut haben und
dann sind da also irgendwie mops überall
und da sind dann skelette sowie sondern
in seiner achterbahn in einer
geisterbahn quasi es gibt auf jeden fall
richtig viele coole sachen die da
gezeigt wenn wir mit dekoration sachen
und das ganze zu verschönern mit wegen
wir haben hier
einfach die ganz normalen sachen wovon
achterbahn lebt also diese rollercoaster
tracks et cetera
wir haben hier dinge um das ganze zu
färben und auch zu verbinden und milieus
einzupacken und hier dinge die in
zukunft noch funktionen finden werden
also eintrittskarten et cetera
und ich würde sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat und euch somit zu gefallen
die einfach so richtig geile sachen
hinzufügen egal ob jetzt noch eine
entwicklung sind oder nicht sondern dass
ich schon mal zeige keine kommentare
lasten daumen hoch ein schreibt mir
eventuell eine mod die ihr richtig geil
findet die ich in den nächsten video mal
vorstellen soll
und dann würde ich sagen freunde wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder ich
bin halt so ein bisschen eingesperrt in
einer achterbahn und